hey 42 here it's common knowledge that
the inhumanities carried out by the nazi
party
under the reign of adolf hitler during
the second world war
were unspeakably horrific but here's
some
little known facts about hitler and the
nazi party
that you might not know
[Music]
during world war ii nazi scientists
developed an experimental cocktail of
drugs
containing oxycodone cocaine and
methamphetamine when they gave the
cocktail to test subjects
they gained almost superhuman powers
and were able to march over 90
kilometers a day
whilst carrying a 20 kilogram backpack
without any fatigue when berlin
fell two nazi submarines declined to
surrender
and instead remain submerged for two
months before landing in argentina
one is said to have offloaded a nazi
officer before it was detected in 1945
u.s president dwight d eisenhower
predicted that people would try to
dispel the fact that the holocaust
ever actually happened so he
ordered innumerable pictures to be taken
of the nazi crimes
to hinder any such attempts
a german soldier during world war ii
called werner goldberg
was branded the ideal german soldier
because of his physical appearance
ironically
he was half jewish the nazis were
animal lovers many nazi leaders
including hitler
and hermann goring were ardent
supporters of animal rights and
conservation
the nazi party even introduced animal
protection laws
and laws that limited the hunting of
animals
hitler himself even became a vegetarian
towards the later stages
of his life in 1939 nazis formed a plan
to counterfeit the british pound
to cause hyperinflation and send the
british economy into
meltdown using a german concentration
camp
they manufactured over 132 million
british pound sterling which is the
equivalent
of 7 billion pounds today
their plan was a partial success the
nazis believed that germans as a race
were superior to
all other human beings but it wasn't
only
germans that became nazis the nazis
kidnapped
hundreds of thousands of polish children
whom they deemed to be racially superior
and forcibly germanized them after the
war ended
only 10 percent of them ever returned to
poland
which is a striking example of the
nazi's brainwashing power
the nazis were obsessed with invading
switzerland
it's no secret the nazis were always
fond of a good invasion
by june 1941 they had invaded and
occupied belgium the netherlands
luxembourg
france greece denmark yugoslavia
norway and poland switzerland however
has a famous
long-standing neutrality it never takes
sides
but the nazis had no intentions of
respecting that
hitler hated switzerland he called it a
pimple on the face of europe
they put all their effort into invading
it but it wasn't an easy task
due to switzerland being surrounded by
perilous mountains
so they eventually gave up
hitler loved a good joke hitler had a
small collection of favorite jokes that
he enjoyed telling
over and over again his all-time
favorite was one day mrs goring came
into the bed chamber
and found her husband waving his field
marshall's baton
over his underwear herman darling what
are you doing
she inquired i am promoting my
underpants
to overpants the germans
gravely feared and hated secret police
force
the gestapo was headed by heinrich
mueller
widely regarded as a purely evil
individual
who presided over countless tortures and
executions during the war
mueller was seen in hitler's bunker the
day after his suicide
but after that he completely vanished
never to be seen again to this day
he is the most senior member of the nazi
regime
whose whereabouts are not known many
people involved with the nazi regime
have said that they believe he is still
alive
and it is rumored that he escaped to
south america
but he still manages to elude police
detectives
when the nazi party held its first book
burning
one of the works destroyed was an 1821
play
by heinrich hein which contained the
famous line
when they burn books they will in the
end
also burn people the united states gave
asylum to nazi war criminals for decades
and subsequently tried to cover it up
until they were sued under the freedom
of information act
although widely disputed it is thought
that nazi doctors
were the first to identify the link
between smoking
and lung cancer because of this the
nazis were
very anti-smoking and launched one of
the first
ever known anti-smoking campaigns
the nazis tried to cure homosexuality
by forcing homosexual inmates to have
sex with
female sex slaves coco chanel
founder of the chanel brand was a nazi
spy
chanel loved power so naturally she
found a home
amongst the nazi officials not only did
chanel steal her famous perfume
chanel number five from the jewish
family that financed it
but she also got them to pay her living
expenses
the nazis plan to turn the whole of
moscow
and warsaw into artificial
lakes the nazis were responsible for a
lot of advances in technology
hitler commissioned the designer of
porch to create an
everyday car that looked like a beetle
this was the start of volkswagen
literally
meaning people's car the new car was a
huge success and became one of the most
popular vehicles in the world
hitler was also an enthusiastic
supporter for the construction of
autobahns
he pushed for the world's largest
network of roads to be built
across germany being the first ever
freeway system
the autobahn was a legendary feat of
engineering
that has since been emulated by britain
and america
a member of the nazi party was also
responsible for creating
modern day rocketry as we know it
aerospace engineer werner von braun was
a member of the nazi party
who basically fathered modern-day
rocketry
since world war ii he has become a u.s
citizen
working at nasa and he developed the
saturn v
booster rocket that helped man finally
reach the moon
after the second world war more than 7
000 nazi sympathizers committed suicide
in addition to 6 million jews the nazis
also killed an equal number of
christians
catholics and homosexuals inside
concentration camps and finally
pretty much every nazi official who knew
hitler
didn't like his mustache but hitler
loved it
his secretary once outwardly told him
that she didn't like his mustache
to which hitler replied if the mustache
is not a trend now
it will become one soon because i am
wearing it
thanks for the view subscribe for more
you